Wesley thank you so much for joining me
today I wanted to ask you can you tell
me a little bit about your chess
upbringing I yeah yeah for sure so I was
born in the
Philippines and I learned Chess at
around 6 or 7 years old my father taught
me and my sister the movs because he
just bought an extra board at the market
and uh you know it was my goal to beat
him and I might should do so and I
started playing my neighbors and in
chess Phil sorry in the Philippines
chess is a popular Pastime sport uh many
people know how to play uh not
professionally but uh I just truly enjoy
the game my favorite subject in school
was Matt and and uh chess is my favorite
sport I started reading books and I
started joining weekend tournaments and
then I won the under 10 age group in the
field Philippines in 2003 and started
representing uh my country International
in international competitions and my
rating went pretty quickly after that in
2004 I reached
2160 and 2005 2200 in 2006 I reached
almost 2500 so my progress has been
pretty pretty fast and then uh in 2012
when I was uh
17 I decided to accept a chess
scholarship here in St Louis
Missouri uh was number 100 in the world
and I uh practic as a bonus I practiced
the university with a lot of different
Grand Masters uh from different
countries and that tremendously helped
my and the rest is history basically
yeah for sure and then became
professional 2014 thanks for the help of
my family it's fascinating to hear that
you are passionate about math and uh you
started learning chess at a young age in
the Philippines which you know was tough
for you I think as a kid what influenced
which book would you say influenced you
the most yeah my favorite books growing
up was books by pandini by Bruce
pandolfini he's got a lot I think one my
very first book was stps and saps and uh
it was basically E4 E5 and Tred to make
black and the other one
is what it
like uh Bobby Fisher's most outrageous
chess
moves
and yeah I mean it's interesting growing
up in the Philippines because the
players there rely more on intuition
than than book I mean American Kids rely
on encyclopedic knowledge but in the
Philippines is more
intuition and uh yeah I believe chess in
the Philippines was better
10 15 years ago than what it is now they
don't really have any support for
athletes right now or for a long time so
it was good that I switched but also
interesting growing up there when you
were around 15 was that around the time
when you decided to become a
professional player I don't know when I
became a grandmas at 14 I thought I want
to try to reach
2600 and when I did so I wanted to reach
2700 although that took forever
uh it's it's hard to say it's just when
you're a kid you can be ultra focused on
one thing like Mishra for example you're
Ultra focus on getting a goal
2600 and
and uh feels like there's nothing else
you want to do at the moment than
achieve your goal and then I I was I was
also homeschooled for two or 3 years
during high
school but but I never really thought I
would become a just professional until
maybe when I reach top 10 the world as
many years later and you are mentioning
that in the Philippines you feel that
people are focusing a lot on intuition
while here more on openings um how were
you able to get interested in um you
know memorizing openings well I had a
friend who was providing me with the
latest books and databases and he always
told me you need to learn you need to
learn more openings because back then my
openings was very
limited and he said it's very hard to
kept saying it's very hard to win you
keep playing the sebes only with black
and you need to learn more openings you
need to be able to play everything and
uh mean openings is not everything but
it's true that if you only play one line
then it's going to be very difficult to
win especially in this day and age what
is your your way of memorizing ing the
openings do you spend a lot of time on
the computer do you practice over the
board as well yeah I mean it's changed
now because the engines have become a
lot stronger but back then I was buying
a lot of uh physical opening books and
reading them from page from first page
to the last page they're playing them
with a board was time consuming trying
to memorize them but they always said
you should understand the lines and not
memorize it so you know totally agree if
you don't understand it it's hard to to
get to memorize them yeah for sure but
now it's now chess has really changed a
lot stockfish has become a lot stronger
and also there's live Book Live
databases which weren't which didn't
exist 15 years ago so I don't know how
effective opening books can be now like
physical opening books maybe they still
are for for starting players but I think
for my level I don't really really read
opening books anymore and for a short
period of time you were a coach you were
coaching the US teams at one of the
olympiads do you see in the future
becoming um a coach or do you think
you'll always continue your career as a
professional player yeah it's
interesting it's hard to predict the
future
but I mean been professional for a long
time we'll see how it goes I mean I need
to improve my results clearly but
they're two very different things and
yeah you know I don't want to be a good
player and a bad coach but we'll see for
the fure see where it goes yeah yeah I
mean I'm turning I'm turning 13 in one
week so I think interesting
there um we'll see how we'll see how it
goes there always times in your life for
return a new chapter but but now you
have the US Championship to focus about
so let's focus on the chess I'm very
grateful to St Louis for hosting
tournaments like this thank you very
much Wesley I wish you good luck and
looking forward to seeing you thank you
yeah
[Music]
thanks